up and down on his lap appearing to
engage in sexual and call that the
reverse Santa
the pair I think we could call that
approaching the band magistration that's
a good old-fashioned chair stacking yeah
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population to you
population stowing
yay you're here we're so happier to see
you it's great to see you oh my gosh
this is so fun you brought a
lighthearted book with you show them the
books
men who hate women we're just trying to
understand look I think it would be a
lot thicker
it shouldn't it shouldn't it
part A it's gonna be like that could
have just been titled men
1A
subsection a uh well I just opened it up
it says chapter one men who ate women
chapter two men who pray on women
chapter three men who have women chapter
four men who blame women it keeps
getting better oh my God none of those
people at the bottom it says very short
epilogue a few good
the movie chapter 10 men who hate men
who hate women wow
chapter 11. he wants to join the book
club
you can at least very Kaufman of Maine
chapter 11 Open Mic Comics
um anyway welcome back to dumb people
yeah I like this set it's very fun thank
you the world is dumb the world's
getting Dumber dang dumb and like it's
just getting way more okay to be dumb
yeah like how dumb you are you will find
a Facebook group that says you're one of
us get over here get over here we're
right I've never identified more than I
have now as an elitist
I'm and you got pushed into it you
didn't go to like I don't want this you
guys you were marginalized into I'm a
normal human you're like a person who's
a psychic who gets like psychic messages
I don't want this palette I don't want
this power of elitism I don't want to
hear people I'm a woman of the Dead
relatives so anyway we try and make
sense of it through this wonderful world
our our fan send the stories and then
not like the last time you came we've
sort of switched it up a little bit each
of us do a story me Jay and Dan so dance
are you the first one all right
yes here we go sent in by Brian W Lance
and then they wrote you got to be
blanced ah you gotta be yeah it's a
Desiree song
um
Ellen Cleghorn did a Desiree yeah spoof
on SNL about OJ you gotta run fast
we gotta get away from him I gotta get
down when you're in a car chair at
blance 79 okay with a z here we go uh
headline is this couple caught having
sex in Toowoomba Courthouse tolumba
feels Australia let's we go for a yoga
retreat in Mexico
I'm sorry well two of them it sounds
like a noise you make when you're having
sex
is that the spot no let's make that
noise uh so they're in the corner in the
Tomb of courtroom they're like this
we're gonna do this maybe they said all
rise and he just did he just did
public sex I never I've never understood
that that has to be sure no no that has
to be part of it yeah like the We're Not
Gonna I can understand people being like
do you wanna do this right here with no
one wants we can't understand you know
what I mean like someone who's an
alcoholic yeah that's true I'm so glad I
don't have to deal with that yes it's
just the part where people they want
other people to want I guess that's like
exhibitionism but so Dan when I was a
kid like a little kid and I'd be in a
swimming pool and they'd be like Adult
Swim all the kids out of the pool I
would like stay in the pool till the
very end and like they were just I'm
just gonna say there was a little
tingling feeling down in my loins and I
might have been peeing but just I think
the excitement of like um
we shouldn't do this I'm assuming that
might be part of it yeah getting
reprimanded I mean there's definitely I
mean men I've been with who would like
me to be more like teacher Mommy to them
but like you know all my years working
at bars I understood that people would
like uh to very happily uh consenting
people would sneak into a bathroom and
want to go [__] each other I got that
but they're not a bathroom I don't get
the bathroom like
I think yes I was the only woman in the
green room and they were talking about
uh somebody going off and having sex
with several women and one night in the
bathroom at this club there wasn't any
of them but it was something they knew
okay yeah and it's just like oh our
world is so everybody we're so damaged
no female orgasms were happening in that
bathroom no not one not us including Top
Gun even if the only thing not even four
times even even yeah that's maybe like
how did he reload he's maybe fooling
around in there I don't know that he's
having sex every time or or I guess it
could have been Coke but yeah they
assumed it was I mean the other but the
other thing is like Viagra even if
you're smelling just the soap like the
bath all those kind of smells that come
out of a bathroom also like even like I
feel like men's piss has like a three
meter reach of Splash if I was holding
onto the wall getting you know what I
mean yeah
no like that is it's to me the point
no but the bathroom says and he got four
people to cut consent to the idea that
there's nowhere else for us to go yeah
right this is it the club gave you a
hotel room right yeah just keep people
in the lobby and like yeah that's
terrible standing
too much effort unisex is we're gonna
get caught and maybe again that's part
of it I think the only time I had
standing sex recently was when I had
covet so my mouth needed to be facing
you're like I need to be in a different
direction I have to go I love that
you're like
my legs are so weak machine you're into
events this has to end quickly I can't
breathe glasses are getting fogged by
the mask that I'm wearing a young couple
who had public sex in a courtroom foyer
foyer this is not the bathroom has been
sentenced for their quote outrageous
behavior after a court heard it was
simply a exuberance of affection right
I'm so excited about the verdict right
that's one way to select a jury
chemeka Julie leading
s-h-a-m-e-k-a Shamika shimeka
Incorporated
both of them
chemeka Julie leading was due to appear
in Toowoomba magistrates Court in June
28 2022 for an unrelated matter so
sometimes you're waiting for something
she's out in the foyer and she's waiting
to go in am I going to play Candy Crush
she was there and being supported by uh
soon to be very supportive supported by
her partner this name Jake James Quinn
Jake James Jake not Jacob Jacob James
Jake Jake James Quinn If His official
name is Jake James said sorry his poor
name would be Jake James Jake Jim James
yeah
Quinn Jake Jim what about JJ Quinn yeah
JJ Quinn J Quinn I'll I'll take I'll
take a change is a cool name JJ Quinn is
like a jazz saxophonist sure yeah or
like a top top this guy's a jazz
saxophone defensive man
in the Uptown three or something
everybody's got a great name here the
police prosecutor who goes by the name
of Cameron Francis Cameron Francis is a
great friend cam can't Francisco
Cameron Francis said the couple were
captured on CCTV moving to she has a
website called only friends
only cams
moving through seating in the Eastern
end of the of the courthouse public
waiting area where leading straddled
Jake James yeah and the pair began to
kiss quote vigorously so they're just
kissing about what time when do you
think this took place in in the
courtroom 101 103 PM 12 30 p.m so like
just after lunch you've been out and
around which you know is they always say
you always want to have your hearing or
meeting with the judge in the afternoon
yeah always because they've eaten and
they're happier if you do it in the
morning and they haven't eaten or they
start get hangry it's a real thing that
public defenders will tell you they give
out more Stern sentences in the morning
than they do in the afternoon is it
wrong for me to want her to have said to
him please come in my Chambers
one of the videos that keeps coming up
in my Tick Tock feed is this one judge
who's like so he's awesome nice you know
the judge and he's like talking to the
old guy about it to the yeah to the
woman who's like who's it who who's with
you in court and she's like this is my
daughter and she comes over and she's
like is your mom a good mom and she's
like yeah she's a good mom and she's
like I didn't know about where to park
and I had to pick her up from so-and-so
and he's like you got three other
parking tickets it's the greatest
nine minutes there's an old guy he's
like 88 and he's like he's like what are
you here for and he's like I I um I got
a thing saying seven years ago I went
through a red light and the judge is
like it took us seven years to find you
and he's like yeah he's like you know
what seven years we took we didn't do
our job and he goes well do you remember
why you were driving fast he goes no I
don't remember I don't know my wife
passed away and she goes oh she used to
make you good food oh my God if my
he's like he's like yeah my grandfather
used to run a Fruit Stand and the judge
goes I believe my father worked for your
grandma no way yeah yeah and then he
goes you know what you get out of here
get out of here so like you know it's
coming you know that I hope he treats
everybody like I I'm so wary like I know
that's real everything I watch I mean
also I was just Gaslight out of my brain
so like I don't trust anything which I
get people like eat this I'm like is it
poisonous
I can't trust anything so when I see
tic-tock videos even there was that
recent one where the little kid the
daddy goes bring me the or grab grab me
the buns or something like that and the
little boy goes up and grabs his dad's
butt at the grill yeah he's like what
are you doing I like I like I think it's
Stables everything with kids I think it
stays yeah and everything with kids I
tend to not like either because I was
like you told them to go spill their
cereal yeah they don't know what's real
when you're parenting or when we're
making a video right the kids videos
stress me out I know unless they're just
talking to somebody for some reason the
judge so to me if that judge had caught
these two people having sex I would like
to see him oh you know he probably made
him he would have made him get married
do you love her
let's do this I can do that I can is
right here
that's for their full name we are
cousins they're like oh he also probably
was like Jake James you want to change
that while we're here
JJ you want JJ uh okay all right what
time did you say she said 103. I say uh
10 19 in the morning okay 9 14 a.m okay
uh one of you got very very close this
took place at around 9 20 A.M
she's there for a speeding ticket or
some sort of citation or whatever and
then they decide
hey we haven't had sex yet this morning
let's go down to the East End of the
floor I can't let you go in there and be
all 10. the pair right then began to
have sexual intercourse with leading
caught on camera lifting her skirt and
sitting on her partner and moving up and
down yeah we get how it works
she grown the skirt skirt hooked up her
skirts uh sitting on uh Jake James's lap
and moving up and down on Quinn's lap
the court was told the people who were
walking by what are they like well here
we go the court was told the couple
stopped what they were doing after they
were approached by security and leading
got off of Quinn who attempted to cover
uh who attempted to cover himself she
doesn't have a problem he's out she's
out
this is the argument for men's skirts
straight up skirts tilt it killed it so
the security guard walks away
yes
I know she's I know she wants to get
loose the security officer left the area
and Quinn then exposed his penis again
no and leading adjusted his penis under
her skirt and she sat on his lap a
second time facing away this time wait
there were face
first
she's striving at that point yeah she's
struggling away and again started hoping
up and down on his lap appearing to
engage in sexual let me call that the
reverse Santa
[Laughter]
I believe we saw that approaching the
bench that's a good old-fashioned chair
stacking yeah
the officer time to stack the chairs
honey the security officer uh had left
all right the pair continued until they
were again interrupted by a volunteer
Court staff member but continued once
again after the staff member left this
is they gotta finish plenty of times for
eighth we're finished third time or
finish
she's not doing it like just keep going
you're going to have 12 Angry Men
for a third time the couple were
approached Again by security and leading
quickly stood up and held her arms out
an attempt to block the view of the
security got one of the cartoon yeah
Flynn attempted to cover himself she's
like no no no no no that's happening
nothing nothing to see here my boobs are
up here yeah the couple left the waiting
area which was full view it was it was
full sorry it's waiting it was full of
people on the right full of people the
camel the couple the couple left okay
waiting area which was Full Ahead of a
busy course for members of the public
less than 16 feet away from them she was
on his docket oh my God that is so um
we're almost near the end of the story
how old do you think these two little
[__] are and I say that with lovely
yeah same age same age do we know what
they were called in for by the way no
public India
going too fast I will say this peeping
toe uh they are only one year apart okay
they could have a time of year where
they're the same age
30 to 40. I think they're 27 and 28 okay
20 and 21. okay
Jake James JJ and she Mecca Julie are
she is 19 he is 20.
put this up on the YouTube channel dude
he kind of looks like wait that's them
wow he looks like Gronk and of course
she is her picture is her looking like
over her like she's on a yacht yeah
she's like who wants like broken into a
zoo before yeah so is this show you look
at this this picture all he says is come
on baby show the pics of them of them
doing it oh yeah CCTV get that CCTV by
the way and that you know is now going
to be a porno I know you're like that
yeah I've been known for that Court sex
on TLC the court was told that they were
easily identified by the CCTV cameras
and on June 30th a couple was issued a
notice to appear by police on Friday the
payer pleaded guilty to the indecent act
in any place to which the public are
permitted access yes and they started in
the courtroom Nathan Boucher said
Quinn's actions weren't planned and that
the unemployed laborer simply wasn't
thinking of how inappropriate their
actions were overcome both unemployed
laborers the leading solicitor she's
about the only explanation of the
couple's Behavior she got laid off
[Applause]
they had been overcome with quote an
exuberance of Youth uh her lawyers said
you guys you can't stop YouTube You
Can't Stop two people who are young
can't stop the body rock 19 in 1920 like
I don't know better we'll get out here
on this magistrate Claire Kelly said in
a disrespectful manner you've taken into
the public Arena a very private act a
couple was sentenced to 60 hours of
community service with no conviction
convictions recorded So this is one of
those things where like you just say all
right come on you can't do that here
that's it you're not like the way three
times but the more you talk about like
it's a terrible act and two people
should only do this in the in their in
the darkness of their
bedrooms
on right lights on you should only be
like dead eyes staring at their eyes
like the person saying it is like all
right Slow Down slow down now you're
putting a lot of you we're not here to
talk about sex we're just here to talk
about word or not it should be between
you and a woman and a girlfriend like a
woman and then you're like well okay no
like just shut up stop talking like
anything this is a hard time believing
that alcohol wasn't involved
it could have been an all-night kids
maybe they just or second addicts so I
think there's some of that I bet there's
got to be they definitely wanted to be
caught he's just a douche he might just
be a dude or she's a douche and he's
impressionable
a couple of douches in a pot and we love
each other I think she probably part of
her was like I want to try this three
times I'm game what if the judge
sentenced them to five more years in
their relationship
two or three they're like I want to end
it no no two more years of this four
years you wanted to have sex
[Music]
um all right that's Story number one
number one uh all right we'll come back
we'll find out what Beth is doing how
you can support her see this great stuff
that she's done and and all the great
have you got a chance to see her do
stand up she's at the tippy top of her
game I will say that we'll let you know
what we're doing right after the break
we'll be right back
around
people Town hey guys welcome back to the
show before we get into Story number two
Randy and I have a few stand-up dates
yeah yeah I'm not sure when this is
going to drop but I think it'll be
before uh March 4th we'll be in
Lawrenceburg Indiana which is right
outside of Cincinnati in Louisville if
you're in that area come see us at the
Lawrenceburg Event Center it's a
humongous room
um and it should be really fun that show
one night one night only we usually
don't go to that area so for those who
are out there come see us at the end of
the month we're going to Phoenix at the
standard live one of my favorite clubs
to do and I love Phoenix so we'll be
there March 30th 31st and April 1st
we're going to be at moon tower then
we're going to be in Minneapolis
Minnesota and we're working on you know
we actually are just said yes to the
state in Springfield Missouri at the
Blue Room happening way in November
we'll be back in Ann Arbor because my
daughter got into college there so we'll
be back there in uh September and we're
trying to put together a couple more we
had so much fun uh but maybe a series of
a couple of shows with us and and some
other uh of our friends up in Alaska
maybe in the fall we'll let you know
when those are coming because we just
had such a good time up there I love
that I love that place in Brad Erickson
up there a great dude all right Daniel
Van Kirk uh every Wednesday the lyric
Hyperion theater Irene too and myself
have a show called The Lyric Comedy Hour
that's at 7 30
um and then I'll be doing a show in
Houston you can keep an eye out for
called would you rather comedy the first
one is on March 3rd
um other than that I'll be in Denver
headlining with the grolix buddies and
then we'll have some Festival
announcements coming up soon uh and I
think Rory skull and I are going to do a
big five-year party probably in Chicago
or somewhere else to celebrate the
five-year anniversary of pen pal that's
that's out in the ways Beth that sounds
fun yeah where can people see you and
catch you and watch your specials and
all that stuff uh you can watch my our
special called girl Daddy on HBO Max
amazing special shot at the Varsity
Theater in Minneapolis tag uh last tag
by the Scarborough we had a couple
attacks or one tag in there which I love
love yes it was a killer tag did it work
the end yeah
um that's all I care about did it work I
have a half hour on Netflix but that's
kind of old yeah
um I'll be and tell you right for the
Fest Comedy Festival such a fun fest
I've heard have you been before this is
my second year do you like it yeah I
mean I don't ski uh I tried it for the
first time in my life last time I was
there oh wow and I'm good yeah yeah I
was exhilarating I'm glad I tried
something new yeah your good as in like
not I'm a good skier I'm good I tried it
yeah I'm good did a double green and
then I'm out yes it's pretty good
um next so yeah that's next week I guess
or whenever that is whenever this comes
out the February 21st I'll be in San
Diego doing a show where are you doing
it I don't know I think it's called
American Comedy it's belly up nice okay
cool we love it Solana technically and
then
um March 3rd I'll be in Ann Arbor nice
the Blind Pig oh nice blind Pig's
awesome great good for you I love that
you're doing um a rock venue that's a
really cool rock venue very very cool
spot I love it and I don't know what
else because I I don't know
bestdelling.com Birmingham it looks like
maybe late March uh we'll tell you where
to eat in Ann Arbor okay
um enjoy that but let's get into stuff
let's do Story number two why not let's
do it car thieves caught after stopping
at McDonald's to get something to eat
what's wrong with that you get hungry in
the middle of thieving right yeah you
need some time
in the ramp up to a car theft sure
you're not thinking about did I eat
probably some anxiety yeah right I know
this answer I know this answer but Jay
who sent it Carly McDermott okay
thank you of all four of us would any of
you steal a car have the first idea
would you steal a car before you ate at
McDonald's yes would you rather steal a
car
of how to steal a car no way no way I've
thought about it only because where were
we it was me and Moe Welch and Atlanta
Johnson we're leaving bubs and in the
alley a guy had just gotten out of his
car he was his door wide open car
running and he just like walked back
into his house through the garage and I
was like let's take it take it you could
totally take it it would be fun to just
move it 20 feet I thought about just
driving it to the end of the alley yeah
yeah
that would be so I don't have public sex
end of the alley though is like a great
bit Yeah end of the alley is like MMA
comes out to and then you just want to
be
hey do you see someone do that no no I
would be like I don't I think that's
where you parked right like I would just
take this roll and I stopped it yeah
says kids my mom ran back into the house
and we started I guess rolling down the
back door and you were in the back seat
yeah and a guy ran out of his car got in
and pulled the emergency brake oh my God
I did that once after an accident for
another person but hero oh my God that's
wild and that guy became your father
your stepfather I wish I got a way worse
one yeah you could count on that first
guy though yeah were you doing a podcast
with your mom yes she just commented on
Facebook yesterday she was like when are
we gonna do more episodes oh man she
still don't know how is she Ohio yeah
that's what I thought remember when we
hung with your mom in Montreal yes it
was so sweet also by the end of the
story I want to know all your McDonald's
orders oh yeah we were going wrong
car thieves who stole how much worth of
luxury cars this is going to be in uh
wait do they each have a car this is
like swingers they each have their own
Parts they've sold
many cars uh not in this month they get
caught in a car but okay how much have
they stole over time and this is in
British Pounds British pound in terms of
money money yeah money worth of luxury
cars Beth what do you think I mean look
I'm worth a luxury car oh luxury 100 000
pounds right so no more than that right
what a luxury cars could be like 400
right so I'm stolen
over a million over a million say a
million I'm gonna say five million
yeah I'll just say three okay I'll go
one one million all right uh carthy
stole who stole 500 000 worth of lunch
right that's still alive
cars footy footage show showed the
moment when Rory Fitzgerald Harry
Beresford and Zachary shelis by the way
all sound like they are judges in the
British system the Great British breaker
named outside of Detroit did you say
judges on The Great British Bake Off
yeah they could be that too uh were
arrested as they ordered their burgers
and fries at the takeaway in on Bristol
Road in Birmingham you got cocky you're
like this is the but isn't it true that
McDonald's in other countries is like
nice I think it's still food people feel
they're like we should go there we have
rules they're like wait they're like
they feed us yoga mats yeah we don't
care didn't they say that it was um
bread in Subway we had yoga mat material
in it yeah yeah oh that's kind of good
linked the group all from Birmingham to
more than how many stolen cars including
500 000 VW golfs
there's how you know that it's only 500
000. Mercedes benzes and BMWs how many
stolen cars
six that's what I was gonna say imma say
four uh 12 12. six I say 12. I'm gonna
I'll go ten okay uh they have been
linked to more than 20 stolen whoa okay
so like one Mercedes one BMW and then a
seven golf seven golf like should they
be arrested for not shooting higher than
a golf yeah like I feel like that could
be one of their offenses uh the men
admitted conspiracy to steal motor
vehicles and conspirated conspiracy to
burgle homes between the 28th of June
and the 16th of November 2020. that was
during covid you [__] and we're
jailed at Birmingham Crown Court on
Friday Fitzgerald was jailed for I I
mean I we could just say yes eight years
beds for jail for six years three months
shelis was sentenced to five years and
five months behind bars they should be
sentenced to eating McDonald's
everywhere that's what I think every day
you know one of them wanted to stop and
one didn't yeah come on come on man for
you last time you you needed that
birthday card and we stopped hopefully
that's the one who got six years
I said no I said no police had been
hunting the tree after they were spotted
trying to break into garages just before
midnight on 17th of November 2020. they
drove off empty-handed in a black
Peugeot
I don't know who wrote this
aren't bad they're not bad with a
distinctive show is better they drove
off on a black dog a space saver wheel
on the back so there's like a spare
wheel on the back so it's like easy to
identify the car
traffic Patrol picked up the vehicle 30
minutes later and followed it into a
McDonald's drive-through where all three
were arrested on suspicion of burglary
look if you well this is what's your
last meal like what's your meal oh yeah
this is your final meal Mickey D's I
don't I don't know how to pronounce this
go for it I'm gonna sound dumb because
that's okay d-a-l-a-c-l-a-v-a-s
baklavas
and gloves were found in the car and
examination of their phones this is
where they're dumb so they're dumb
already they're dumb to go to McDonald's
they're posting videos of them stealing
cars here we go a video on their they're
not posting but they're on their phones
also assist Aaron on the balaclavas by
the way all right thank you Aaron video
showed uh Fitzgerald rummaging through a
woman's handbag this is a following a
burglary in Aldridge before making off
of their BMW while ransacking the house
they filmed the trio one can be heard
singing I don't just take cars me I take
the big Telly as they steal a 55-inch TV
a 55-inch TV I'm sorry is not that big
of a team it's pretty big it's not that
big it's not that big it's big like a
[__] pujo is a luxury car is that
what I have I don't know you probably
have a 55 or 60. it's very common yeah
it's what size is a big TV and then
that's what I got I went with 80.
I love that it's it's my own little
movie theater yeah I have a 70 and I
love it you have to have a place big
enough to sit far enough
dance right in front of it
no no no I can't did you hear that
they're gonna now start charging
different amounts
like an airplane yeah I'm always middle
middle usually like you're J you're J to
your L 19 to 12. why would they be doing
that when you aren't already going
anyway thank you we're gonna make it
more difficult at a theater yeah what do
you like usually like closer to near
near the back that are a little left
yeah okay back Center left some people
is that your politics too yeah
I like my politics like I like my
theater seats
rose gold just told me he likes an eye
like on the end
like you're like this the whole time
looking off I'm like centering a little
front row but I'll go to the movies
when's the last time you were inside of
a movie theater a week ago a couple
weeks ago yeah
I did the AMC thing I went and saw it
was a gift where I go for free
documentary type thing about the guy who
invented the bulletproof vest really it
was pretty interesting wow that's an
amazing thing it's like a pathological
liar but we've done it was great too so
we've done stories on dumb people town
of two just like dudes in Arkansas
yeah yeah I mean that's what this guy
did he would that's how he got like to
be one of the biggest I can't think of
his name yeah did he figure it out but
he kept on shooting himself but it was
all based on what appears allegedly like
a lie
and it just there's a lot around it I
mean they work but then like it they
don't work like you definitely want the
person who developed your bulletproof
vest to be somewhat trustworthy well I
agree and they've worked for a while it
was just it's the the deeper tail was so
interesting that it was of it was
basically the classic tale of of
dumb son seeking father's approval uh
always always this there's like footage
like and his dad was like a war vet like
real tough and so there's footage that's
very strange between them yeah
what is it called shot through the heart
I don't know I should look it up there's
one thing I wanted to look up to because
my friend Jordan lives in Milwaukee and
there's they're called like the the it's
not venga boys but like the something
Honda boys they steal cars they steal
cars yeah the Honda boys there's
something in Milwaukee going on right
now and we're like really behind the
boys so this article is a serial killer
in Chicago right now the police said
after being arrested in the
drive-through we initially charged him
with three offenses but the full scale
of their offended became clear when we
analyzed their phones that's it don't
take a video of you yeah
boys
uh they broke into homes for keys to
high performance cars like VW golfs
it's a good you can soup them up
no victims were confronted but they
caused damage to homes worries for
victims and lots of inconvenience yeah
police recovered 12 of the stolen cars
including one VW Golf
filled with rappers from McDonald's
that's right yeah I want to know
everybody we'll get our orders when we
finish this up last line here uh two of
them are Mercedes-Benz is taking from
the same Brahms Grove were worst worst
to share worse to share uh driveway on
October 2nd 2020. they took two cars
from one driveway
um all right let's get into it
is before before we get out of here what
is Beth I'm assuming you haven't been to
a McDonald's Maybe ever or no I mean I
have I used dude what was your order
what's your order I mean obviously
breakfast is best for sure and their hot
cakes are good and I love like an egg
and cheese biscuit yeah but if but my my
meal or your adult dinner meal the game
in high school or something like that
yeah you're on the road and you have no
other yeah it would be the two
cheeseburger meal
cheeseburger fries no pickles no
pictures or your meal no pickles
I love pickles separately and their
pickles were always so tall they do have
a different floppy thing you don't want
it just on the sandwich is different
yeah if you're gonna do pickles on a
sandwich I want it to be a crisp Dill
like and at like or like you get a good
Cubano like a good oh yeah I'm down I
love pickles I never was but now I'm
kind of like that on with the on the ham
um in it uh mine is a 20 piece McNugget
and barbecue sauce it's insane because I
know it's like not but like if you if
right now today we get done and you are
having a who gives a [__] that you would
still go get it I would go 20 piece
McNugget in fries and I'd be like give
me honey mustard and give me barbecue
sauce because whatever they put in those
things like to me it's all about dipping
it in there yeah a vehicle for that I
just I love ketchup so much grow up and
I still love ketchup but as an adult
it's I'm more aware than ever that it's
basically sugar yeah but it's
interesting how much it's so good God
damn it's good what's your order mustard
you know I'll be honest quarter pounder
with cheese I used to be I used to love
myself
I'll go a double cheeseburger no onion
and the reason I go double cheeseburger
instead of quarter pounder is it's way
easier to uh don't you hate when you're
about to tell comic something you're
gonna make fun of you yeah
like Dan you're the master of let me
tell you the better way to do it no for
me because it's so much easier to take
off one of the buns and then I can I
just eat half the bun with the other
stuff so I'm like saving a little bit
it's got a head you're trying to be
healthy by going to McDonald's I used to
go grilled cheese or grilled chicken
there's no more grilled chicken why are
you going grilled chicken at McDonald's
if we're on the road and you're like
basically like pink liquid that they put
in a mold yeah it stopped you mean the
yeah the painted grill marks yeah so but
if I can get two sausage egg and cheese
biscuits you're happy so take one of the
half of those off and then give me a
double cheeseburger because I just I
don't know
in New York in the 90s in 1994 five
you're walking in they had it they had
something called the arch Deluxe I don't
know if you remember the arch deluxe
burger at at McDonald's and it had Mayo
on it it was so good yeah it was so good
it was like there's something about it
that it feels like me I might have
lettuce Deluxe stay like are we at like
is it somewhere between I'm sorry am I
embarrassed right now what is happening
like am I dress nice enough to have the
arch blocks I I would ask myself that a
couple and wait would you get one or two
I think I would get one and I do think
what was it just a cheeseburger but it
was Mayo between a quarter pounder and a
Big Mac yeah and it had lettuce and it
was so good and onion special box
special box I knew it at a special box
so I think their fries are really good
and they're still really good the fries
yeah all of it's good okay got it yeah
no I was just gonna say I have to pee so
bad I'm getting chills so we're gonna
take a break you go pee and we'll be
right back and I uh when we come back
I'm just gonna tell you we got a woman
doing uh maybe the greatest thing ever
during a sobriety test we'll be right
back with best-selling and more uh dumb
people town right after this
all right guys welcome back to the show
I'm gonna bring us home I got a third
story Beth Stelling is with us
bethstelling.com follow her on so on
yeah your social stuff is fantastic all
the old clips of the stand up and and
whatnot is just great take us home Randy
I will take us home okay and I will put
this video funny because we always end
by going back to work so I should say
take us back to work I'll take you back
to it I'll take I'll take you to the
point because we've all been in writers
this is what we describe the show it's
like a writer's room where before you
want to really start working everyone's
like oh have you seen you've seen this
crazy have you seen this thing and then
you're ripping about that and then
you're like oh [__] back to work so
that's what we say at the end of every
show here we go really stick I've got
Pete just texted me like two days ago
remember when you said yeah
that feels good that's a good one that's
good Chris Delia looks like Mr Burns
okay that is that is actually I've never
heard that ever yeah
sent in by Reagan at regante 13. I don't
think we've ever had this person sent in
thank you regonte the president of the
United States of America Ronald Reagan's
handle will hey all right uh Deputy
impression good timely impression
contextually
Nancy yeah
I don't remember
okay
uh deputies released
deputies released video of a Florida
woman doing Irish folk dance during
sobriety test so at that point you're
like I'm gonna lose
well I'm gonna go out swing or you're so
drunk you have full-on drunk confident
you have like so you'll show them how in
control I am
yeah this is everybody looks drunk Irish
dancing
yeah they tried to commit Michael flatly
to it yeah you're like halfway house
pull him over I mean yeah they go hand
in hand really so there's the Great Clip
from Reno 911 right she said everybody
thought was real for so long it's the
favorite funniest it's pretty much the
funniest thing on the planet it is the
actor who plays the drunk guy was like
the perfect amount of like what if I do
a kickball chain and then I'll do a
barrel kick and then I go spin it over
that way and go ah
Wendy Wendy disco okay
what are you doing and then she guesses
like she's like that's pretty good
you're a dancer he's like oh no I'm just
drunk
that's the best part just a brilliant
movie good classic like that is what I
would do I would reference I would
reference that if I were these I mean
that in every swordson what do you do
down here Terry what are you guys doing
oh we got called here oh I got calls
here too
but he runs across the park in roller
skates
running a sheriff's office in Florida
has just a sheriff's office in Florida
that's enough where where is it be
specific it's in Florida this is in
Pinellas County Florida okay has
released footage of a woman who
performed multiple ballet and Irish folk
dance so they let her go at a certain
point they were they were fighting it's
like our Christmas video right now
they're like we're gonna just count this
yeah what else you're gonna wear
yourself thank you during a road how
many calories did she Burn yeah deputies
with the Penelope sheriff's office said
the suspect identified as a woman from
Madeira Beach okay we'll guess her age
in a minute had rear-ended another
vehicle roughly one mile from her home
on April 27th when deputies arrived they
said the driver showed several signs of
impairment including bloodshot glassy
eyes dilated pupils and a willingness to
get up and shake it
if that was in there I'd be like why
aren't we doing that when asked to walk
the line the woman struggled to follow
instructions and was unsteady on her
feet almost falling arrest Dan Dan
you're right in her mind she's like I'll
show let me show you let me show you
again it's like when Carl Lewis sang the
national anthem and like completely
screwed up and was like I'll get you
back oh like no you won't oh no you will
not get them back whenever I wasn't like
kicking people oh
yeah
no Carl Lewis was a track athlete
so when Carl Lewis is like if I just
type in the word Carl the first thing
that comes when I think is Carlos that's
right okay because YouTube love this
it's also worthy of all the love when it
gets there um one of the greats I
remember
track athletes in our history when I
wasn't kicking couples out of the
bathroom having sex the amount of
conversations I would have with drunk
people to be like no no you can't like
[Music]
you're not Marvin Gaye
you're like okay he's got it
nope nope oh he said oh that's
everything I'll make up for it now no
you won't
go there like no there are basketball
players biting and they're eating their
clothes
[Laughter]
struggle to follow instructions and was
unsteady on her feet almost falling
arrest document said uh the newly
released video the deputy administering
a field sobriety test can be heard given
the suspect instructions at one point
the woman responds and says yeah well
you sound like my ballet coach
[Music]
yeah something tells me you still you
don't still have a ballet coach right
you're a little old to be in ballet this
is like when you're on a first date and
you try to gear the conversation towards
things that you are comfortable talking
about
what are you gonna order I don't know
ever since I was little I've Loved cats
oh my gosh I love kids too and then
you're off to the races so she's trying
to be like oh can I tell you this true
story yeah this is real sure so I used
to be a federal agent and my boss Jack
Phillips told me that uh to get out of
any sort of like speeding violation or
whatever
don't ever say like hey I'm a federal
agent don't show your badge the one
thing they would say is like keep keep
your ID with your badge then you have to
show your badge today yeah you have to
show you when you open it up and they
see that one of the things he would
always say is what she just did where uh
you sound like my boss down at the
federal agency or you'll be like you
know what my brother-in-law is always
telling me the same thing and then the
cop will go who's your brother-in-law
and like oh he's a police officer in
Madison or whatever I'm like oh you're a
fan like that's how you drop it in you
drop it in she is doing this perfectly
being like you sound like all right the
woman then took five steps along the
line before transitioning into a ballet
sequence
imaginary line reminds me of
that wasn't the exercise that I was
demonstrating the deputy says without
responding the woman then leaps into
what appears to be an attempt at folk
dancing mixed with
martial arts
you know how like most people when
they're doing ballet you go to like the
folk dancing
you started the bullshoi in in Russia
and Moscow famous company they just
immediately after their dancing and
plieing and you know Potter Beret and
all that other stuff they'll then just
go right into folk dancing of course the
sheriff office said the woman uh later
refused testing which marks the second
time she refused the test after a
separate incident in Pinellas County on
March 3rd deputies also said they found
what was your question I'm just saying
like I it's so interesting that you can
refuse to test oh you should always
refuse I mean definitely but why are you
allowed I mean that's the part that's so
strange to me like definitely refuse
yeah definitely refuse but then yeah
because it's only probable cause or it's
uh like they don't have a warrant well
here's here's what allows that's why you
can refuse it you're gonna get the DUI
later you well most lawyers will be able
to get you at least like a work permit
driving but you could literally look
into a camera and go I'm so drunk right
now right into their dash cam or body
camera as long as you don't blow any
lawyer will be like your honor he
thought he was just whatever they wanted
to say are here to get this over with he
was just trying to comply with like you
can lie around anything here's something
she said except for the number that
comes out when you write here's
something she could have to do about the
Dan here's something she couldn't deny
deputies said they also found a white
cup containing a yellow uh light yellow
liquid that smelled of alcohol in the
center cup holder of the woman's skin oh
she had a roadie you can't have a one
for the road a little cocktail Rose
driving Under the Influence property
damage Sushi damage property and
refusalem I clipped one mail box why is
that doing an Irish jig what is a
problem I may have done more damage
dancing let me know I can't dance I'm
gonna try and get a video of this woman
dancing because I really oh you have it
we'll also put it up on the YouTube
there's like a commercial at first okay
here she is let's get it here she goes
we'll put this up on the thing come on
you come on come on anyway let's see
while while this is coming up I want to
find out from you guys how old do you
think she is
oh it's probably locked oh There She
Goes she's dancing oh there's the J oh
there it is there we go I'm gonna be
honest not that good she's dancing this
is very funny it is great and there's do
you think when she got done the cop was
like you're going to Hollywood
you know I I think it would try to make
it a little more sexual yeah I also love
that they really gave her the floor they
really like stepped back then she got
another flashlight and was like okay now
she's doing folk dancing and she's
dude she did do a little bit of a Miss
cop girl get back on her what are you
doing right there and then she's doing a
little bit of a jig oh my God oh my God
this is this is like Jay said this is
the Christmas company Christmas party at
the precinct this is their video that
they run I think she did try to sex it
up a little bit but she did and she's
actually not that she did show some my
daughter takes ballets she looks like
well she's trying to get me to go into a
car wash she's she so I think what this
was is a bit of a trip into a dance move
oh yeah she's trying to do the line and
can't so she's gonna dance the line
we're missing out on is whatever song
she's singing out loud
wow she's gonna try and dance
how old do you think that get now that
you've seen her how old all about that
base no trouble I'm gonna go for 36
years old wow I went 24. 24 Jay what do
you think I'm gonna say she's 47. okay
47 get your answers in townies Beth
Stelling it's been just a joy a tree to
have you here I love it I love hanging
with you every time you guys are sweet
this gal
dancing it up just going from not being
able to walk the line to a ballet move
into folk dancing said this guy reminded
of her ballet teacher mortis of the
dance which like Dan you said it's not
gonna help you in any way everyone like
just because you reminded of the ballet
teacher doesn't then get you out of
anything better my ballet teacher is
also a federal agent now you're out of
it she is 38 years old
yeah
okay now we do it 38 by the way looks
great for 38 and is kicking ass like
whatever dancing at the moves I was on
point as it were there you go she was
too old to be drinking and driving that
is true
it was too old to be singing the weekend
yeah
I love it there you go that is a show
guys we love you so much thanks for
listening thanks for uh watching on this
journey thanks for watching on all
things companies YouTube page you know
[__] we gotta get back to work
[Music]